which gaming mouse is worth spending
your hard-earned money on
well in an effort to answer that
question today i'm putting two heads
ahead
the customizable king the razer naga pro
and the more budget-friendly steel
series
rival 3. if any point you like the sound
of these mice you can check them out in
the affiliate links down below
but if you want to learn more about
these well then stay tuned because we
are going to break them down together
first of all let's talk about price
because there is a big difference in
that department
first of all the razer naga pro comes in
at 149.99
or 149 pounds and 99 pence and secondly
the rival 3 wireless
comes in at 49.99 and just shy of 55
pounds
so the razer naga pro is three times the
cost
of the rival three but is it three times
the product
when it comes to the specs though there
isn't as much difference as you might
think razer's naga pro has up to 20
000 dpi and the steel series rival 3 has
up to 18 000 still pretty high numbers
and
probably more than the average gamer
needs both have a thousand hertz polling
rate so
pretty even there the only real
difference is is when it comes to the
sensor
razer uses their own focus plus sensor
which has an apparent
99.6 percent accuracy and steel series
has their own true move air sensor the
naga pro comes with its own dongle so
you can use razer's own hyper speed
2.4 gigahertz wireless or you can use
bluetooth if you feel like
you haven't got enough usb slots or
there is also a cable for if you want to
charge
or use it wired now the steel series
also has bluetooth
it also has a 2.4 gigahertz connection
with its own
dongle but it does not have any wireless
adaptability
if you want to go wireless you are stuck
wireless the naga pro has between 100
and 150 hours battery life while the
steel series rival pro says that it has
a
year-long battery but we'll get to both
of those points
again later in the video the unique
selling point for the naga pro
is of course the three panels that it
comes with so you can choose between six
buttons
two buttons or of course 12 buttons
these will attach to the main body of
the mouse with a nice satisfying
click and their whole purpose is that
they're designed around different genres
of games
with a two button option for first
person shooters a 12 button option
for things like mobas mmos and a six
button option
based around the battle royale genre i
will say i did wonder how much use
i'd get out of these i'd come from a
mouse where i'd only had
two buttons and i did immediately find
it quite tricky
to find 12 small buttons with my fat
thumb
but as i started to experiment i found
more and more
use and more and more utility out of
these panels
going from using my number pad to six
buttons on the side of my mouse
was a little bit of a learning curve but
once i was there i did honestly find it
really intuitive quite easy to use and
made me want to
experiment and kind of push and see what
else i could do with them
so in escape from tarkov i was able to
use my med kits that little bit quicker
in dota 2 i was much more confident in
using my active items
and i thought um i can use these buttons
to get to the build mode
in fortnite a bit quicker and maybe i'll
be able to compete with all the
sweaty school children that dominate
that game
didn't work but i must say it did all
give me confidence to start seeing how
far i could push the extra utility of
these buttons
so i would assign them hotkeys in things
like adobe premiere
and it would improve my workflow
somewhat
but it also did a strange mental thing
where i would go from
the two button panel and that was like
gaming mode
to the six button panel it was like work
mode
so i was that was how i differentiated
my my work time
and my game time with mouse buttons
so what i suppose i'm trying to say is
that they really are as useful
as you make them out to be but having
all three
in a package i think it's only going to
be applicable to you if you're a gamer
that plays
all games if you're only going to play
one or two or only gonna find
use out of one or two panels it might
get to you that there's a piece of
plastic
that you've paid a good chunk of money
for unutilized
in your desk drawer but that does mean
with the biggest panels this mouse can
have
about 20 customizable buttons which
offers
a lot of utility if you're willing to
put in the work
and program them the ptfe fee on the
bottom means that it glides across your
mouse pad like buttered
teflon it has a real nice sturdy build
quality to it with the
rubber pads on the left and right side
meaning that you're
really not gonna drop this thing and it
features probably
the quietest click that i've had in a
mouse
this is mostly down to the fact that
this thing uses optical switches rather
than mechanical ones so
a little beam of infrared light rather
than an actual clicky switch
now these offer a response time of 0.2
milliseconds which is about
25 faster than other options according
to razer so this thing is customizable
comfortable and quiet enough not to
disrupt your discord friends
or be overheard while you're streaming
but how does the rival 3 stand up
the first thing i want to mention though
is that the rival 3 uses
two double a batteries this is one of
the reasons why the price point is lower
because they haven't had to
engineer an internal battery but because
they're situated at the back
i found it much less comfortable to use
this might be a personal preference but
when i was moving it across
the mouse pad during games normal web
browsing work
i found that it felt heavier than
the naga pro despite all in all this
package batteries included
is actually lighter it was just more
unwieldy
you can use it with one battery and of
course you get half the life then
but no matter what i was using it for
what grip i had it in
whether i was gaming no matter how much
time i gave it
i really couldn't stop noticing the
weight of the junk
in this thing's trunk to its credit
though it still has really great build
quality
it's sturdy there's no flex in the
plastic but you are getting
normal mechanical switches with a normal
clicky button
but again that's one of the reasons why
the price point for the rival 3
is so much lower but there are people
out there that prefer that tactile
mechanical feel
and don't care what discord server they
disrupt with it
there is more to be said on the subject
of connecting these things to your
computer though
with both of them being able to use 2.4
gigahertz wireless with the included
dongle
and razer utilizing their hyper speed
tech but when it comes to bluetooth
the rival 3 does take a hit
the performance hit the rival 3 takes on
bluetooth mode is severe enough
that i would say it's almost a different
mouse i can't recommend using it
on bluetooth for long periods of gaming
when you're in bluetooth mode you're
forced to their default bluetooth
settings
it takes that 1000hz polling rate and
forces you down
to 125 and in bluetooth mode you also
miss out
on any acceleration or angle snapping
features that you may have enabled it
kind of neuters the gaming out of this
gaming mouse
now using these things on bluetooth is
going to prolong the battery life
or the time between having to swap out
those double a's
but in my opinion you've got a lot of
power in both of these
free up a usb slot put the dongle in and
get what you're paying for
they do have some battery saving options
to make those charges
go a little longer the idle time can be
turned up and down so that if you leave
your
mouse to one side for a little while
it'll turn itself off and the rival 3
when you're using it and moving around
will disable the rgb
because your hands on it the razer has
quite
a lot of rgb but it will remain
illuminated as you're using the mouse
but steelseries said what do we need to
illuminate your middle finger for dave
which turn off
save those double a's now of course to
play with all those rgb
and power saving settings you're going
to have to use the software that comes
with the mouse
because it's current year and that's how
mice work now i will say though that
razer synapse is much more feature-rich
it has more utility when it comes to
remapping all the buttons monitoring
battery
changing your lights and it was all
extremely easy and i was extremely
impressed with the amount of options
that i had when it came to the
customization utility
basically allowing me to set up any
macro or shortcut that i wanted
off the back of the 19 plus buttons on
the naga pro
the steel series engine is still a great
utility and does allow for some
flexibility when it comes to changing
your settings for power management its
sensitivities and
using in the built-in acceleration angle
snapping features but there is
definitely less utility when it comes to
macros and remapping
but honestly still more than enough
there for the majority of gamers
but when it comes to which one i think
is most worth it
it's honestly closer than i thought it
would be
in the case of the naga pro it feels
like a specialized
tool for whatever game i'm playing you
have to put a little work
to get it there but once you get the
buttons to what you want them to be
you get comfortable with the side panel
it really does
feel like a mouse that was built for a
specific genre but you have the option
to change genre it's like having three
mice almost
whereas in the case of the rival 3 with
no offense meant
it's just a mouse a really really good
mouse a great mouse
but in comparison it is just a mouse
but does all of that warrant the massive
price difference between these two
honestly great pieces of kit well
in the case of the naga pro again going
back to the side panel issue
i'm only ever going to use two of them
so it is a source of frustration knowing
that there is a piece
of plastic and circuitry that's worth
good money
sitting in my drawer but with all that
being said it's so
comfortable it performs so well if i was
being honest with myself it probably is
my favorite
mouse of all time but that high price
point
really is a sticking issue when it comes
to the rival 3 though you really
are getting quite a lot for your money
sure you're going to have to swap the
batteries out
it might not be as feature rich as the
naga pro but
for an entry-level wireless mouse or
something for the mid-range gamer
or someone who just wants to try the
wireless life on a bit more of a budget
i think this one is most worth it if
you're someone that wants those high-end
peripherals has the money to spare
if you're playing lots and lots of games
across genres or just wants the best
gaming mouse money can buy
maybe you'll go for the naga pro because
i do think
this is the best gaming mouse on the
market right now
but i think the rival 3 is more worth it
if either sound like that'd be up your
street then you can use the affiliate
link in the description below to get one
for yourself
if you've used either of these in the
past let me know your thoughts in the
comments section down below
and please tell us what things we should
compare next keyboards
monitors headsets the world's our oyster
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of those like the video
let us know if you've enjoyed and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you